-The House voted
to impeach President Trump
for inciting last week's
Capitol insurrection,
making him the first
and only president in history
to be impeached twice.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Today was historic
in many ways,
not the least of which was
the President
became the first in history
to be impeached
for a second time.
As far as anyone can tell,
he has no discernible defense,
no legal strategy,
and very few allies left
outside of the House GOP.
Several of his lawyers from the
last impeachment have bailed,
his former home, New York City,
revoked all its contracts
with him,
his banks and major donors
are all fleeing.
Even Mitch McConnell
has signaled
that he might be willing
to turn on Trump.
-According to
"The New York Times,"
Senator Mitch McConnell
is pleased
that Democrats are moving
to impeach the President.
"The Times" reporting
that McConnell believes
the move will make it easier
to purge President Trump
from the Republican Party.
-Axios is reporting that there's
a better than 50-50 chance
that Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell
would vote
to convict President Trump
in an impeachment trial.
-That's significant,
because if you watch movies,
you know "pleased" is
the highest level of happiness
for villains.
"The emperor is most pleased
with your efforts, Lord Vader."
Of course McConnell is pleased.
He's like a guy
who robbed a bank,
jumped on a helicopter to Fiji,
and pulled up the rope ladder,
leaving his accomplice
stranded on the roof
as the cops close in.
"Mitch, Mitch, come back."
"Uh, sorry, Donald. I can't
hear you over the rotors."
[ Laughing as Mitch McConnell ]
Even Trump's most precious
friends in the world,
his closest allies,
his wingmen and therapists,
the Fox & Friends are torn
about whether to stick
with Trump or bail on him.
-Why fracture unnecessarily?
-Because, Brian,
you're talking about
people who work in the Congress,
and we're talking about
the Congress was under attack
last week.
It was looted. There was a riot.
-So is Portland every day,
and nobody cared on the left.
-Brian --
-Those people have lives, too.
Just because they don't
have medallions
to go through metal detectors
every day.
All the state houses
and the police houses
that were ransacked,
and nobody cared?
-I don't think what
they were doing in Portland
was trying
to overthrow democracy.
-Police stations?
-Let's put the shoe
on the other foot.
If a Democratic president --
a Democrat president
did what happened last week,
a week ago today,
would the Republicans
in the House and the Senate
move to impeach him
if they could?
The answer is yes.
-Guys, guys,
you're both terrible.
Man, I'd say that was the worst
thing to happen to a group
of friends this week,
except they announced
they were making
a "Sex and the City" reboot
without Samantha.
How's that even going to work?
Three women in a coffee shop
talking thoughtfully
about their lives
and then just a big old
dead spot
where there should be
a delightfully hacky
double entendre about sex.
"Harry says it's a turnoff
that I'm so anal retentive."
Oh, right, she's not here.
But you know
you've sunk to a new low
when you're a Republican getting
reprimanded by Steve Doocy.
Do you think
if we just let Trump
fly off to Mar-a-Lago next week
without consequences,
that'll be that
and everyone will just move on?
He incited a violent mob
to attack the Capitol.
I can't even put a new
welcome mat in front of my door
without getting reprimanded
from my co-op board.
So with a handful of his closest
allies abandoning him
and no way to communicate,
Trump has basically gone silent,
even as his name is officially
disgraced in history forever.
-This day that the President
is likely to be impeached
in a historic manner
for the second time,
the only president
to ever be impeached twice,
and he has no legal strategy
right now,
and he doesn't even really have
a legal team put together.
There is no
comprehensive strategy
happening behind the scenes.
The President
is basically invisible today.
-I'm sorry, I was just enjoying
the words "Trump is invisible."
Do you know how hard it is for a
guy like Trump to go invisible?
He's not exactly stealth.
He's invisible the way my kids
are during hide-and-seek.
Hmm, either they've
left the country,
or that giggling curtain
is a clue.
And, honestly, however you feel
about the merits
of the Twitter ban,
it's a huge
quality-of-life improvement.
It's like waking up
the morning after
construction finally stops
outside your window.
We no longer have to put up
with President Jackhammer.
In fact, the last time
we saw Trump was yesterday
when he flew to Texas
to defend his seditious speech
that whipped up
the violent mob
and celebrate the entirely
useless monument to racism
he forced us to pay for,
despite scamming his supporters
into thinking
it would be paid for by Mexico.
And if it's the last time
we ever see him on camera
as president,
I think it'll be fitting
because it ended
in the most pathetic way
imaginable,
with him quietly slinking
off the stage by himself
as "YMCA" blasted
over the speakers.
♪♪
I hope that's remembered
alongside Nixon on the chopper
as the last time
we saw him as president
because it is the opposite
of the strength
he tries to project,
just moping away
during a Village People song
like he just got kicked out
of a wedding
for trying to hit on the bride.
"How was I supposed to know?
Oh, right,
the white dress and the veil?
Oh, yeah, and the groom
did give her that ring.
Oh, and the vows."
And it is a testament, a true
testament to the Village People,
by the way, that even after
that pathetic scene,
that song still slaps.
When they eventually arrest
Trump for sedition or incitement
or tax fraud or extortion
or campaign finance violation
or, I don't know, any of the 87
crimes he's probably committed,
I hope they play "YMCA"
during that perp walk.
I mean, he already dances
like he's trying to wriggle
out of a pair of handcuffs.
I also really hope that wasn't
the song that was
supposed to play.
I really hope it was
a small act of resistance
by whoever was running
the soundboard,
that they were supposed to play
"Hail to the Chief"
or something.
But as they watched
this sack of depravity
wrap up yet another
lie-filled speech,
they thought, "[Bleep] it.
I'm playing 'YMCA.'"
-♪ It's fun to stay
at the YMCA ♪
-So whatever else happens
after today,
it'll be inscribed
in the Congressional record
and in the history books,
and it'll be a stain
on Trump's name forever.
He's the only president
to get impeached twice.
In fact, it's worse than that.
He's the only president
to be impeached twice
and lose the popular vote twice.
He'll be emblazoned in history
as an embarrassment
and disgrace.
No politician
has ever been more thoroughly
and more frequently repudiated
by the American people.
It's like entering
the Tour de France,
coming in dead last, and getting
kicked out for steroids,
then entering again
the next year,
only to forget your bike,
forcing you to steal
someone else's, and scream,
"You'll never catch me,"
before crashing into a cow...
In 2016,
he lost the popular vote,
in 2018, he lost the House,
2020 was impeached,
lost the popular vote
and the Electoral College.
In 2021, he lost the Senate,
and then he was impeached again.
It's almost like
he's tanking the season
so he can get the number-one
pick in the jailhouse
fantasy draft.
"I'll take Madoff. Hey, Bernie,
I got some real tax issues."
If nothing else happens
after this, at the bare minimum,
Trump will be an answer
to a Trivial Pursuit question.
They'll have to devote
the entire card,
that little section at the end
where they give you
an extra tidbit of information.
"Who's the only president
to be impeached twice?"
"Huh? Donald Trump.
And it says here,
'He was impeached for trying
to extort a foreign country
to help him cheat
in the 2020 election
and then for inciting
a violent insurrection
after losing that election.
And also, he told people
to inject bleach
during a deadly pandemic
he failed to stop,
tried to ban Muslims,
called Mexicans rapists,
paid hush money to cover up
an affair with a porn star,
and his lawyer
held a press conference
at a landscaping company,
and see attached brochure
for more.'"
Wow.
But as notable as it is
that a few prominent Republicans
broke with Trump today,
the fact remains
that the vast majority
of the House Republican caucus
sided with him even after
he incited an insurrection
against the government
a week ago.
A majority of that same caucus
voted
to overturn the results of
the election at Trump's behest,
even after the violent mob
ransacked the Capitol.
And now Republicans
have the gall
to blame Democrats
for sowing disunity.
-What I'm trying to suggest
to you is that both sides
are at fault.
-This is a reckless impeachment.
This will only bring up the hate
and fire more than ever before.
-In seven days, there will be
a peaceful transfer of power,
just like there has been
every other time in our country.
But Democrats are going to
impeach President Trump again.
This doesn't unite the country.
-You don't merely seek victory,
but you seek obliteration
of your nemesis.
-Every movement
has a lunatic fringe.
-That's your defense?
Look, every movement
has armed militias
with tactical gear
and zip ties
and detailed plans
to seize the Capitol
and Confederate sympathizers
and a Q-Anon antler man.
You guys are talking about this
like your [bleep] teenage son
TP'd the principal's house.
"Look, we've all been there.
You're young and impressionable.
You downed a few Natty Lights,
and you tried
to overthrow democracy.
It happens. Look,
he's graduating in seven days."
Also, stop saying
Trump is committed
to a peaceful transfer of power.
That ship has sailed or, rather,
that ship was boarded by pirates
and steered into the rocks.
You guys tried
to overturn an election.
You sowed an insurrection.
And now the Capitol has to be
protected by the National Guard
because there are credible
threats of violence
from the President's supporters.
That's not peaceful.
You don't get to throw a brick
through your neighbor's window
with a note saying,
"Trim your hedges,"
then when you get caught say,
"Okay, okay, fine.
Let's just barbecue this out
and put it all behind us.
Yes, I broke your window,
and, yes,
I terrified your family,
but you got a free brick."
Also, it's truly disgusting
to suggest
that holding someone accountable
for stoking violence
will itself stoke more violence.
Try that strategy
in a courtroom.
"Look, if we anger OJ
by convicting him,
he's just going to
murder again."
But just to give you
even more of an idea
of how crazy these people are,
here's Ohio Congressman
Jim Jordan
and Colorado Congressman
Ken Buck
rambling through
their usual spiel
of empty slogans
and right-wing buzzwords
about, honestly, God knows what.
-They want to cancel
the President.
They spied on his campaign
before he was elected.
Nineteen minutes
into his presidency,
they started
the impeachment push.
Three-year
Mueller investigation --
19 lawyers, 40 agents,
500 witnesses, 2,500 subpoenas,
$40 million to find nothing.
Impeachment round one, based on
an anonymous whistleblower
with no firsthand knowledge,
who was biased against
the President,
and who worked for Joe Biden.
It's not just about
impeachment anymore.
It's about canceling,
as I've said --
canceling the President and
anyone that disagrees with them.
The ayatollah can tweet,
the President can't.
-This House spoke over and over
about impeaching the President
days into his administration.
And then the socialists
in Hollywood
joined their allies in Congress.
Robert De Niro said
that he wanted to punch
the President in the face.
Madonna thought about
blowing up the White House.
Kathy Griffin held up a likeness
of the President's
beheaded head.
And nothing was said
by my colleagues
at that point in time.
-The President is being
impeached for inciting
a violent insurrection,
and you're talking about Madonna
and the ayatollah's
Twitter account?
What the [bleep]
is wrong with you?
Is Jim Jordan a real person
or just a haunted doll
with a string on his back?
Listening to these guys is like
far-right slam poetry.
Mueller spy, Madonna lie,
the ayatollah's
a Twitter guy.
Although, I have to say,
the take for me
that is mind-blowingly dumb
is the argument
that impeaching a president
for inciting an insurrection
to overthrow democracy
is cancel culture.
"They're trying to cancel
the President.
One day you can't go to Costco
without a mask,
the next day, you can't try
to overthrow the government.
What's next?
Soon they're going to say
you can't go to Supercuts
with a garbage bag
and ask to collect
the loose hair on the ground
so you can paste it to your head
like I do.
When will cancel culture end?"
These people are deranged.
They never fail to make
themselves the victims.
And they think
they're above the rules.
They think
they're above democracy.
It's why they think
they should be allowed
to substitute their own judgment
for the will
of 81 million Americans
who voted for Joe Biden.
It's why when you
politely ask them
to walk through metal detectors
a week after the Capitol
was seized
by right-wing terrorists,
they ignore them
and whine about them
and lose their minds
like Nicolas Cage
in "The Wicker Man."
-[ Screaming ]
-The President and his allies
in the GOP and right-wing media
have spent years
feeding their rabid fan base
deranged lies and fantasies
of violent retribution,
culminating with the effort
to overturn the election
in a violent insurrection.
Trump watched it,
gleefully encouraged it,
and even when
members of Congress
pleaded with him to stop it,
refused.
And in the end,
just 10 Republicans
voted to impeach him.
If you're asking whether
it should have been more...
-The answer is yes.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.